What how I met your mother means to me is that grief is temporary whether I've had a fantastic day or a terrible day watching that show is always the right move for the mood.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》对我而言意味着，悲伤总是暂时的，无论我今天过得是多么美妙还是多么糟糕，看这部剧总是能契合我的心情。
And there was this wonderful show.
而且还有这样一部精彩的剧集。
That was all about how the randomness of life is what gets you exactly where you need to be.
它讲述的正是生活中的种种偶然，如何带你去了你命中注定该去的地方。
Welcome to how we made your mother, which I think we're calling.
欢迎收听《我们是如何创造老爸老妈的》，我想我们是这么叫它的。
This is our new podcast rewatching 208 episodes of how I met your mother.
这是我们的新播客，带大家重温《老爸老妈浪漫史》的208集。
I'm Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德诺。
and I played Ted Mosby on the show for nine seasons.
我在剧中饰演了九季的泰德·莫斯比。
And I am thrilled to be joined by Craig Thomas who co-created the show along with Carter Bayes.
我非常高兴能与克雷格·托马斯一起主持，他和卡特·贝斯共同创作了这部剧。
Josh, somehow it has been 20 years since our show premiered.
乔什，不知怎么的，我们的剧首播已经20年了。
That can't be right, your math is off.
这不可能对，你的算术有问题。
It seems wrong, I'm sure it's wrong, let's check it, but it's also been 10 years since the show went off the air and while deeply disturbing, it makes it a good time to look back.
这似乎不对，我相信它不对，让我们核对一下，但这也意味着该剧完结已经10年了，虽然这深感不安，但也正是回首往事的好时机。
Well, if you're a super fan, we're gonna get into all the secrets, theories, easter eggs, slash pineapples, and general knowledge.
如果你是一个超级粉丝，我们将深入探讨所有的秘密、理论、彩蛋、斜杠菠萝，以及各种冷知识。
General knowledge?
冷知识？
But we'll also use him-yim and our relationship to it, these 20 years later, to talk about life and love and art and everything in between.
但我们也将利用这部剧以及20年后的我们与它的关系，来谈论生活、爱情、艺术以及介于其中的一切。
And just like the show itself, this podcast doesn't exist without you.
就像这部剧本身一样，没有你们就没有这个播客。
Your voices will be a big part of what we do.
你们的声音将是我们所做工作的重要组成部分。
I'm alone, and I won't be soon in New York City.
我独自一人，而在纽约市，我不会孤单太久。
Tell the people listening.
告诉听众朋友们。
How many times over has your wife, Tornana, seen how I met your mother?
你的妻子托尔娜娜把《老爸老妈浪漫史》看了多少遍？
It is zero times.
是零遍。
But we have a section called questions and observations from a clinical psychologist, relationship expert, who's never seen how I met your mother, who also happens to be very Josh.
但我们有一个板块，叫做“临床心理学家、恋爱关系专家的提问与观察”，她从未看过《老爸老妈浪漫史》，而且碰巧她也非常乔什。
Is that title too catchy?
这个名字是不是太上口了？
We are now embarking on this rewatch together, our her first watch rather.
我们现在要一起开启这段重温之旅，准确地说是她的首次观看之旅。
A couple of times when I was looking at Robin in a certain way, she would go, I know that look.
有几次当我用某种眼神看着罗宾时，她会说，我认得那个眼神。
I'm gonna see you, please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
我要去见你了，请允许我在纽约市把一切都告诉你。
But there's one guy owned the bar, he had never been off the island of Mallorca.
但有个家伙拥有这家酒吧，他从来没有离开过马略卡岛。
He said, How I met your mother has taught me that what's happening now will be my memories one day.
他说，《老爸老妈浪漫史》教会了他，现在发生的一切终将成为他日后的回忆。
So make sure that you're making good memories for yourself in the present moment.
所以请确保自己在当下为自己创造美好的回忆。
And this old man, he must admit he fell in love with you in New York City.
而这位老人，他必须承认他在纽约市爱上了你。
I'm excited to unpack this stuff, and it feels honestly, it feels like psychologically healthy for me to do this, you know, it feels like are you ready to go back to the Titanic?
我很兴奋能剖析这些东西，说实话，我觉得做这件事对我的心理健康很有益，你知道的，这感觉就像……你准备好回到泰坦尼克号了吗？
We're marrying March 10th.
我们将在3月10日结婚。
Learn more at HowWeMajormother.com
了解更多信息请访问 HowWeMajormother.com